.
HOPE YOU GOT YOUR SLEEP BECAUSE
IT'S NFL SUNDAY, BABY, LET'S GO.
YOU HAPPEN TO BE THE BETTING
"SQUAD RIDE" BLEACHER REPORT AD.
I'M CONNER ROGERS ALONGSIDE THE
MAN AT THE FIGHT LAST NIGHT,
GREG, HOW WE FEELING TODAY?
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> FEELING GOOD, CONNER.
FEELING REALLY GOOD.
FEELING SO GOOD IN FACT, I'M
GIVING AIRWAY HOODIES TO THE
PEOPLE IN THE K07COMMENTS NOW.
I GOT JONATHAN THAT SAYS MICAH
PARSONS ALL DAY FOR DEFENSIVE
PLAYER OF THE YEAR.
HEY, YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
>> WE'RE GETTING INTO THAT.
WE'RE GETTING INTO THAT AT SOME
POINT.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT WE GOT TO
START WITH.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THOSE
TOUCHDOWN SCORES.
WE ASKED YOU IN THE APP.
WE ASKED YOU ON SOCIAL.
WE DO THIS EVERY WEEK.
WHO IS YOUR LOCK TO GET IN THE
END ZONE?
IS THIS THE FANTASY PLAYOFFS AS
WELL?
EVERYBODY HAS EXTRA EYES ON
THIS, GREG.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK WHO YOU SENT
US THE TOP ODDS TO SCORE A
TOUCHDOWN.
JAMES CONNER AT THE TOP.
HE'S BEEN A WORKHORSE FOR
ARIZONA BUT DON'T FORGET CHASE
EDMONDS WILL BE ACTIVATED OFF
I.R. THIS WEEK.
LEONARD FOURNETTE REGULAR
SEASON, NOT JUST PLAY-OFF LENNY
ANYMORE.
EZEKIEL ELLIOTT AGAINST THE
BANGED UP GIANTS.
DEVONT
AVANTE ADAMS, JOE MIXON.
STEPHFON DIGGS THAT HAS NOT SCOD
THE LAST TWO WEEKS, INTERESTING
TO KEEP AN EYE ON HIM.
PATTERSON WHO MIGHT BE THE
REASON POSTMOST OF YOU MADE IT
THE PLAY-OFFS THIS YEAR AND
DEONTE' FOREMAN RIGHT THERE, AS
WELL.
KIND OF OUR DARK HORSE ONE ON
THIS BOARD.
SO WITH THAT BEING SAID, AN
INTERESTING BOARD THIS WEEK
BEFORE WE GET INTO "THE SQUAD
RIDE" COMPETITION I'LL SHOW YOU
THE ROCK LEGENDS WE DIDN'T GET
TO SHOW ON OUR PROGRAM.
>> MY PICK TO SCORE A TOUCHDOWN
THIS WEEKEND.
>> WE MIGHT AS WELL MIKE IT
PROFITABLE.
>> EASY TO HOLD THIS.
>> SUNDAY.
>> IN THE GATE AARON ROGERS,
PATRICK MAHOMES, LAMARAVANTE AD
WEEK.
TOM BRADY.
>> ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN SCORE.
LOCK IT IN DEEP.
>> ALL RIGHT, GREG, LET THEM
KNOW WHAT WE GOT GOING ON THIS
WEEK.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE ARE GIVING AWAY TWO, NOT ONE,
BUT TWO NFL JERSEY GIFT CARDS.
THAT MEANS SOMEBODY IN THIS
COMMENT, SOMEBODY THAT IS
WATCHING RIGHT NOW IS WALKING
AWAY WITH A JERSEY AND ALSO, THE
WINNER OF THE ROCK LEGEND
CONTEST IS WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
WHAT I NEED YOU TO DO IS GET IN
THE COMMENTS.
I NEED GIFTS.
I NEED EMOJIS, I NEED LOCKS, I
NEED WINNERS, I NEED TAKES, I
NEED YOU GUYS TO FILL THOSE
COMMENTS UP BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY, FILL THEM UP WITH
WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE.
THANK YOU.
>> YOU HEARD THE MAN.
WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE.
HELP HIM OUT.
HELP US OUT.
FILL THAT COMMENT SECTION TODAY.
LET'S GET INTO THE LOCK LEGEND
TOURNAMENT.
WHO IS GOING TO BE "THE SQUAD
RIDE" LEADER?
WHO IS TAKING HOME THAT TITLE
AND JERSEY AND WHAT ODDS IS GREG
BOOSTING IN DRAFT KINGS TO SCORE
THE TOUCHDOWN?
THE FIRST ONE FROM PROANGLER,
J.B. A FAMILIAR FACE.
WHO IS SCORING THE TOUCHDOWN,
PROANGLER?
>> WHAT'S UP?
INSTEAD OF SENDING SANTA MY
CHRISTMAS LETTER, I ASKED HIM
FOR A LOCK.
THERE WE GO.
JAMES CONNER MINUS 190.
>> THE SANTA LOCK LEGEND GOING
WITH JAMES CONNER AT MINUS 190
BUT YOU CAN DO SOMETHING WITH
THOSE ODDS.
DON'T FEAR THOSE JUST YET.
OUR FIRST COMPETITION OF THE
DAY, THOUGH.
WE GOT TYLER HERE TO CHALLENGE
J.V.
LET'S SEE THAT SELECTION.
>> HEY, B.R. BETTING WE HAVE A
LOCK FOR A FOREMAN TOUCHDOWN SO
WE'LL DO SNOW ANGELS BECAUSE WE
PRAYING FOR IT.
LET'S GO.
>> DEONTE' FOREMAN, THE SNOW
ANGLE LOCK LEGEND.
DEONTE' FOREMAN PLUS 150, GREG.
WE LIKE THAT.
WE LOVE THE PLUS MONEY ON THE
SHOW.
WE HAVE JAMES CONNER, SANTA
CLAUS SENT THAT ONE AND FOREMAN
FROM THE SNOW ANGEL LEGEND.
GREG, FIRST OFF, WHAT DO WE NEED
AND HOW WE FEELING ABOUT THESE?
>> WELL, FIRST OFF, I NEED
EVERYBODY IN THE COMMENTS TO LET
US KNOW, LET ME KNOW, LET CONNER
KNOW WHICH WAY ARE WE RIDING?
ARE WE RIDING WITH JAMES CONNER
OR RWE RIDING WITH FOREMAN?
I'M ACTUALLY -- I DON'T KNOW
WHICH WAY I WANT TO RIDE WITH
THIS ONE.
I KNOW WE DO KNOW THE IMPACT OF
JAMES CONNER, CONNER.
WE KNOW THE IMPACT OF HIM.
EDMONDS BACK IN ARIZONA IS
COMING BACK TODAY.
IS THIS GOING TO AFFECT JAMES
CONNER TOUCHES?
I DON'T KNOW.
HIM SITTING AT MINUS 190,
CONNER, THAT IS A LOT OF JUICE.
DON'T BE ALARMED.
YOU GUYS KNOW WHAT WE CAN DO ON
"THE SQUAD RIDE."
THAT'S A LOT OF JUICE.
IF I'M BEING HONEST.
HONESTLY, I DON'T KNOW.
WITH FOREMAN, TENNESSEE, THEY
HAVE ANOTHER BACK -- LIKE, IT'S
TOO MUCH UP IN THE AIR.
I'M GOING TO ROCK WITH THE
PEOPLE ROCKING WITH.
CONNER, WHICH WAY ARE YOU
LEANING?
>> I'LL DEFER TO THE PEOPLE,
TOO.
I'LL LEAVE YOU WITH THIS LIKE
YOU SAID, CHASE EDMONDS IS
COMING BACK AND NOT JUST GOING
TO COMPLETELY WORK HIM INTO THE
POINT OF NO RETURN BUT NEED HIM
INVOLVED TO GET READY FOR THE
PLAYOFFS.
ONE OF THE BEST FREE SIGNING OF
THE OFF SEASON, THEY NEED A
TWO-BACK SEASON.
THE PASS CATCHER TO GET
INVOLVED.
THEY WILL RAMP UP THE WORKLOAD
THAT HAS TO SQUARECARE YOU A BI.
DEONTE' FOREMAN, JUST HIT OR
MISS RIGHT NOW.
RIGHT?
OBVIOUSLY, THERE IS A LOT GOING
ON IN THE BACKFIELD LIKE YOU
SAID.
SO I WILL DEFER TO JAMES CONNER
BECAUSE OF WHAT HE CAN DO ON THE
GOAL LINE, BUT THIS IS A TOUGH
SELECTION.
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE COMMENTS
TO SOLVE THIS ONE.
>> YEAH, I'M IN THE COMMENTS
RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU GUYS DON'T KNOW, THE NEW
PEOPLE TO THE SHOW, THIS RIGHT
HERE IS THE HANDY DANDY IPAD.
THIS IS HOW YOU WIN YOUR HOODIES
AND JERSEYS.
THIS IS HOW YOU GET TAPPED IN.
I SEE EMANUEL SAYS PHX 1 SAYS
WINTER WONDERLAND FOREMAN IS A
LOCK.
WOW.
LIKE THAT.
JAMES CONNER EASY TOUCHDOWN
MACHINE WITH OR WITHOUT EDMONDS,
K SAYS THAT SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
CONNER, THEY'RE BACK AND FORTH
IN THE COMMENTS.
I GOT BRANDON SAYING CONNER, I
GOT MAXWELL IN THE COMMENTS
SAYING FOREMAN I'M GOING TO MAKE
A DECISION HERE, CONNER.
I'LL MAKE A DECISION.
>> CALL IT.
>> I'LL SLIDE IT.
FOREMAN.
WE'LL ROCK WITH FOREMAN MOVING
ONTO THE NEXT ROUND PLUS MONEY.
SNOW ANGELS.
TYLER, YOU-ALL ARE MOVING ONTO
THE NEXT ROUND.
>> DEONTE' FOREMAN, THE UNDER
DOG TAKING ROUND ONE AND THAT
KIND OF PLUS MONEY, PLUS 150,
GREG WILL GET THAT.
WE GOT MARSHALL.
>> WHAT'S UP?
I'M OUT HERE WITH MY PARTNER
LOOKING FOR THIS WEEK'S LOCK.
HERE WE GO.
WE FINALLY FOUND IT.
LET'S DIG IT UP.
>> STEFON DIGGS ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN SCORE.
LOCK IT IN.
>> RETRIEVING THE LOCK OF THE
WEEK IS DIGS THIS IS A LOW KEY
FAVORITE OF OURS AND HE HASN'T
FOUNDED END ZONE SO HE'S DUE.
FOREMAN GOT SOME JUICE FROM THE
LAST ROUND.
TOUGHER OF A MATCHUP HERE,
RIGHT?
>> OH, YEAH, I'M ALL OVER IT.
YOU MENTIONED IT.
WE'VE BEEN ON STEFON DIGGS AND
I'LL ROCK WITH HIM.
I LIKE THE PLUS MONEY MORE THAN
THE FOREMAN PLUS MONEY I'LL BE
HONEST.
THE REASON WHY, WE TALK ABOUT IT
ALL THE TIME.
IT MIGHT BE THE REASON HE'S IN A
SLUMP RIGHT NOW BECAUSE HE'S
TRYING TO FORCE STEPH FON DI
DIGS -- STEFON DIGGS.
ARE YOU ROCKING STEFON DIGGS OR
FOREMAN?
>> DIGGS.
THIS WAS PLUS MONEY.
LET'S NOT FORGET, YOU SAID IT.
A TRUE NUMBER ONE WIDE RECEIVER
FOR JOSH ALLEN.
STEFON DIGGS HAS GOTTEN DOUBLE
DIGIT TARGETS IN SIX GAMES THIS
YEAR WHEN THE BILLS NEED A FIRST
DOWN OR A TOUCHDOWN OR A BIG
PLAY, THEY LOOK ONE WAY AND IT'S
STEFON DIGGS, RIGHT?
YOU CAN'T SAY THAT ABOUT DENOTE
FOREMAN.
SORRY, NICE STORY LINE BUT GO
WITH WHAT WORKS AND MADE YOU
MONEY IN THE PAST.
YOU'RE RIDING DIGGS, I'M RIDING
DIGGS.
ARE THE COMMENTS TAKING?
>> DIGGS AND ROBINSON SPRINKLING
IT, WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE
BEN THE GOAT 123 SAYS 100% LET'S
G
GO.
WE'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT.
THERE IS NO NEED FOR MORE.
WE KNOW WHAT YOU WANT TO DO AND
WHAT I WANT TO DO AND IT'S CLEAR
AS DAY IN THE COMMENTS, WE KNOW
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO.
WE'LL ROCK WITH STEFON DIGGS AND
LET'S KEEP THIS THING GOING.
>> A BLOWOUT IN ROUND NUMBER
TWO.
I'M SORRY DEONTE' FOREMAN FANS
BUT THIS IS STEFON DIGGS TO LOSE
HERE.
ROUND THREE.
FINAL ROUND.
WINNER TAKES HOME NFL JERSEY
GIFT CARD, "SQUAD RIDE" LEADER,
THE TITLE AND THEIR TOUCHDOWN
SCORE GETS BOOSTED.
SO THEIR BETTING THEM ANYWAY.
GO BACK IN THERE AND GET THE
BOOSTED ODDS.
AARON G. WAILS, DO YOU HAVE
ENOUGH TO KNOCK STEFON DIGGS OFF
THE LEADER BOARD HERE?
LET'S SEE IT.
>> HELLO?
>> REAL QUICK, DIGGS OR ZEKE
ELLIOTT?
WHO YOU TAKING?
>> EZEKIEL.
>> ALL I NEED TO HEAR.
GLAD YOU'RE INFORMED.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THAT SOUNDED
LIKE SANTA CLAUS THERE BUT WE'LL
SAY SANTA ON THE HOT LINE GOING
WITH EZEKIEL ELLIOTT.
DON'T LET THE MINUS MONEY SCARE
YOU.
GREG WILL FIND A WAY TO GET THAT
ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF THINGS.
WE STILL LIKE DIGGS.
WE ALWAYS LIKE ZEKE BUT HE'S
BEEN BANGED UP THIS YEAR AND WE
GOT TO WATCH THE TOUCHES.
FINAL ROUND HERE, GREG, GIVE ME
YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> YEAH, THIS ONE IS ACTUALLY
PRETTY TOUGH, CONNER.
THIS IS TOUGH.
WE HAVE STEFON DIGGS.
WE JUST TALKED ABOUT THE IMPACT
THAT HE IS ON THAT BUFFALO
BILLS' TEAM AND WHAT HIS
QUARTERBACK TRIES TO DO.
HE TRIES TO FIND HIM AND FIND
HIM OFTEN.
THEN WE GOT EZEKIEL ELLIOTT HERE
IN THE A DIVISION MATCHUP
AGAINST THE GIANTS.
WHERE ZEKE USUALLY SHOWS UP IN
THE MATCHUPS, CONNER, IN THE
DIVISION MATCHUPS ZEKE SHOWS UP
SO I DON'T KNOW, MAN.
I DON'T KNOW.
ZEKE SITTING AT MINUS 140.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE CAN DO.
I'LL PLAY IT OUT, CONNER.
THIS IS WHAT I'LL SEE HAPPEN.
I SEE THE COWBOYS GETTING INSIDE
THE FIVE AND YOU KNOW WHEN
THEY'RE INSIDE THE FIVE, YOU
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO GET A
HEAVY DOSE OF.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET A HEAVY DOSE
OF EZEKIEL ELLIOTT SO I THINK I
WANT TO LEAN ZEKE BUT I ALSO
WANT TO SPRINKLE SOMETHING ABOUT
STEFON DIGGS.
BRO, I'M SO CONFUSED RIGHT NOW.
I'M GOING TO LEAN WITH THE
PEOPLE AND COMMENTS.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING?
>> I WOULDN'T BE MAD WITH EITHER
PICK.
THIS IS ISN'T A WEEK WE HAD THE
COOPER CUP WEEKS.
WE'RE BEGGING YOU TO TAKE THESE
GUYS.
NICK CHUBB IS A "SQUAD RIDE"
LEADER.
GREG IS SPOT ON.
DIVISION GAME.
DIVISION GAMES.
YOU KNOW WITH WHAT YOU KNOW AND
FOR DALLAS THAT'S BEEN EZEKIEL
ELLIOTT.
NUMBER TWO, THE GIANTS ARE A
SORRY YOU KNOW WHAT TEAM, GREG.
I GOT ON YOUR I.G. STORY AND
LIKE CHARGERS TEN, CHARGERS
NINE, DON'T CARE.
MIKE'S TURNOVER PRONE.
THAT WILL LEAD TO A LOT OF EASY
POSSESSIONS STARTING ON THE
RIGHT SIDE OF THE FIELD AND EASY
TOUCHDOWN RUN.
THE ONLY THING I HAVE QUESTIONS
FOR WITH ZEKE IS HE'S BEEN
PLAYING HURT, IS THIS A GAME WE
KNOW WE GOT THIS IN THE BAG?
LET'S MANAGE THE WORKLOAD.
THAT'S OVER THINKING HERE.
SO LET'S LET THE COMMENTS TAKE
US HOME RIGHT NOW.
ARE THEY RIDING WITH ZEKE --
>> LET'S LET THE COMMENTS --
>> RIDING WITH ZEKE OR DIGGS.
>> LET'S LET THE COMMENTS TAKE
US HOME.
MANUEL IS BACK IN THE COMMENTS.
HE SAID ZEKE WILL EAT UP THE
GIANTS.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, MANUEL.
YOU ALREADY HAVE A HOODIE.
ELLIE KING FAST HAS --
[ LAUGHTER ]
HE HAS THE VIKINGS CELEBRATING
IN THE END ZONE SO HE'S ROCKING
WITH STEFON DIGGS.
SHUTOUT TO YOU, ELLIOTT.
I GOT JOSEPH.
IT SAYS SANTA DENIERS PICK WOULD
LIKE TO PICK DIGGS, NOT ZEKE.
SO I'M ASSUMING THAT THEY'RE
SAYING THAT SANTA SHOULD HAVE
CHOSE DIGGS AND NOT ZEKE.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, JOSEPH.
I GOT ONE MORE.
MANUEL, MANUEL IS BACK IN THE
COMMENTS.
MANUEL IS IN THE COMMENTS TODAY.
HE'S RIDING WITH ZEKE.
ONE MORE.
HERE WE GO.
DOWN TO EARTH, DOWN TO EARTH
SEND DIGGS INTO THE SUNSET.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
I'LL MAKE A DECISION.
>> CALL IT.
>> I'M GOING TO MAKE A DECISION,
CONNER.
PEOPLE ARE ALWAYS SAYING FADE
GREG, FADE GREG, GREG NEVER WINS
SO GUESS WHAT?
I'M FADING THE COMMENTS.
THEY'RE ALL ROCKING WITH STEFON
DIG
DIGGS.
YOU'RE ROCKING WITH EZEKIEL
ELLIOTT.
I'M GIVING YOU GUYS A LITTLE
TASTE OF YOU GUYS TREATMENT THAT
YOU SEND TO ME.
I'M GIVING IT BACK TO YOU.
WE'RE ROCKING WITH EZEKIEL
ELLIOTT TO SCORE A TOUCHDOWN
TODAY.
LET'S PULL UP THE GRAPHICS SO I
CAN SHOW YOU GUYS SOME MAGIC.
DID YOU GUYS SEE ZEKE YELL
ELLIOOQUE --
EZEKIEL ELLIOTT SITTING AT 140.
POOF.
IT'S NOT MINUS 140 ANYMORE.
IT'S UP TO PLUS 120 THANKS TO
OUR FRIENDS AT DRAFT KINGS FOR
BOOSTING THAT FOR US.
MAKE SURE YOU GUYS CHECK US OUT
ON ALL THE SOCIALS FOR LINKS TO
THE ODDS BOOST.
SEND US SCENREEN SHOTS OF BETS D
VIDEOS AND CELEBRATIONS BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY, MOST IMPORTANTLY,
GUYS, WE WANT WINNERS AND
WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE.
NOTHING ELSE.
>> MAN, I AM SO HERE FOR THE
GREG TURN NOW.
HE'S HAD ENOUGH OF Y'ALL.
ENOUGH OF THE B.S.
ENOUGH OF THE TROLLING.
HE SAID I'M PICKING "THE SQUAD
RIDE" YOU CAN PUT YOUR MONEY ON
PLUS 110 DIGGS.
SHOUTOUT TO A
ARON G WAILS AND
SHUT OUT TO GREG FOR MAKING THE
DECISION.
FIRST TIME WE HAD SOME FUN WITH
IT.
SPEAKING OF THE COMMENTS, WE GOT
MORE LOCKS, WE GOT MORE HOODIES,
YOU HAVE ANOTHER GIFT CARD
JERSEY TO GIVE AWAY.
THE COMMUNITY COMMENT CONTEST
TIME.
THIS IS THE WINNER TAKES THE
HOODIE.
WE ASKED A SIMPLE ONE THIS WEEK
IN THE B.R. BETTING COMMUNITY
STREAM IN THE BLEACHING REPORT
APP.
YOU HAD $100 TO PUT ON DEFENSIVE
PLAYER OF THE YEAR, DEFENSIVE
PLAYER OF THE YEAR.
WHO ARE YOU PUTTING IT ON?
LET'S LOOK AT THE ODDS LEADER
SOS S
SO FAR.
MICAH PARSONS IS SURGING INTO
THIS.
HE HAS THE DEFENSIVE ROOKIE OF
THE YEAR RACE LOCKED UP.
HE'S SURGING INTO THE DEFENSIVE
PLAYER OF THE YEAR ODDS THAN
AARON DONALD, DIGGS AND JACKSON.
DON'T GET A FAIR SHAKE ANYMORE.
NICK BOSA PLUS 2500.
GREG, WHAT DID WE GET THIS WEEK?
THIS IS A PRETTY INTERESTING
BOARD RIGHT HERE.
A REALLY TIGHT RACE, OBVIOUSLY.
>> YEAH, WHAT I NEED THE
AUDIENCE TO DO IS TELL ME WHICH
COMMENT YOU GUYS ARE GOING TO
LIKE BETTER.
I'M ABOUT TO HOP INTO THESE
COMMENTS FROM PEOPLE LIKE YOU
GUYS THAT COMMENTED ON THIS,
THEY SENT US THEIR TAKE AND
WE'RE GOING TO VOTE AND SEE
WHICH ONE WE'RE GOING TO RIDE
WITH.
LET'S START OFF WITH.
HE SAID NICK BOSA, HE'S DOUBLE
TEAMED ALMOST EVERY PLAY CONNER
AND STILL UNSTOPPABLE.
THIS IS A FACT.
I'M A NINERS FAN.
I WATCHED THEIR GAMES.
NICK BOSA IS ALWAYS DOUBLE
TEAMED OR BEING HAILED AND HE'S
STILL HAVING AN IMPACTFUL YEAR.
CONNER, HE'S SITTING THAT PLUS
2500.
>> CRAZY.
>> BRO, IF HE GOES OFF ONE GAME,
JUST IMAGINE IF HE GETS FOUR
SACKS IN THE NEXT GAME.
BRO.
THAT'S GREAT VALUE.
I LOVE THIS.
I LOVE THIS TAKE RIGHT HERE BUT
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON IT?
YOU FEELING NICK BOSA THIS YEAR?
>> THE TAKE IS AWESOME.
YOU'RE BOTH RIGHT.
AS NINER FANS, IT'S CRAZY.
IT'S NOT GETTING ENOUGH LOVE.
14 SACK SEASON WHICH IS NUTS
RIGHT HERE PLUS 2500 ODDS, THOSE
DO FEEL OFF TO ME.
NOW, NORMALLY I WOULD SAY MYLES
GARRETT IS FREE MONEY AT PLUS
300 BECAUSE HE'S BEEN SO GOOD.
HE'S GOT 15 SACKS.
YOU NAILED THE POINT, GREG.
THE VOTERS JUST GO BY THE
NUMBERS.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO LOOK AT
GUYS GETTING THIS WRONG.
THEY WON'T LOOK AT GUYS GETTING
DOUBLE TEAMED OR GUYS DOING THE
DIRTY WORK.
WHO HAD THE MOST SACKS OR
PRESSURES BY ADVANCED DATA,
WHICH IS GREAT.
THERE IS NOTHING WRONG WITH
THAT.
RIGHT NOW IT'S MYLES GARRETT.
YOU'RE BOTH RIGHT.
ONE BIG NICK BOSA WEEK, YOU
MIGHT BE LOOKING AT PLUS 600,
PLUS 500.
THIS IS FAR FROM OVER.
I LOVE THIS TAKE.
>> THAT'S ALL IT TAKES IS ONE
WEEK.
THAT'S ALL IT TAKES IS ONE WEEK.
LET'S MOVE ONTO THE NEXT
COMMENT.
NS SLIM SHADY SAYS AARON DONALD
IS EASILY THE BEST VALUE BET
HERE.
>> DON'T AGREE.
>> I MEAN, AARON DONALD, IT'S
GOOD VALUE.
IT'S DESCENT VALUE FOR AARON
DONALD BUT CONNER, LET'S BE
REAL.
YOU JUST MENTIONED NICK BOSA,
MILES GARRETT AND PARSONS FROM
THE COUNT.
THERE IS GUYS IN FRONT OF AARON
DONALD THAT HAVE A CHANCE OF
ACTUALLY WINNING THEN AARON
DONALD.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE?
ARE YOU IN ON AARON DONALD?
IS THAT EASILY THE BEST VALUE?
>> I'M NOT.
AARON DONALD HAS BEEN THE BEST
DEFENSIVE PLAYER IN FOOTBALL FOR
THE LAST DECADE AND IN TERMS OF
BEST PLAYERS, IT'S BEEN HIM AND
BRADY.
THAT'S HOW GOOD AARON DONALD IS.
THIS YEAR HE'S BEEN GREAT.
THERE IS SIMPLY GUYS THAT HAVE
BEEN BETTER.
I LIKE AT THE STRATEGY BECAUSE
WE'RE TALKING BEST VALUE BET
HERE, RIGHT, GREG?
VALUE BET WOULD BE BOSA.
YOU CAN SPRINKLE HEDGE A LITTLE
ON IT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> ANOTHER BET, MILES GARRETT AT
THE TOP PLUS 300 IS A LOT OF
MONEY.
PUT A REAL BET ON MYLES GARRETT
AND SPRINKLE BET ON BOSA, YOU'LL
COME AWAY WITH A WINNER.
PEOPLE LOOK AT PARSONS AND SAY
HE'S GOING TO WIN DEFENSIVE
ROOKIE OF THE YEAR AND THE AWARD
SYSTEM WILL LOOK AT THAT AS
ENOUGH.
I WOULDN'T GET CAUGHT BY THE
HYPE THERE.
LOVE AARON DONALD.
JUST DON'T THINK ANYONE CARES
ABOUT HIM AS DEFENSE SIIVE PLAYF
THE YEAR.
IT'S HARSH TO SAY AND DUMB TO
SAY.
IT'S REALITY.
AM I CRAZY?
>> NO, YOU'RE NOT CRAZY AT ALL,
CONNER.
YOU'RE PREACHING.
I WANT PEOPLE TO LISTEN TO YOU
BECAUSE MY GUY SPIT FIRE ON A
SUNDAY.
HE'S PREACHING.
HE SAID SPRINKLE ON NICK BOSA,
PUT MONEY DOWN ON MYLES GARRETT
AND YOU'RE WALKING AWAY A
WINNER, MAN.
I LOVE THAT.
YOU'RE PREACHING TO THE CHOIR
RIGHT NOW AND LET ME SEE IF THE
COMMENTS IS PREACHING TO US,
CONNER.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS AND I GOT
LANDON.
LANDON IS ROCKING WITH MICAH
PARSONS.
MUST BE A COWBOY FAN.
THE MICAH PARSONS IS ALSO
BALLING.
MICAH PARSONS IS ALSO BALLING.
YOU CAN SEE THE COMMENTS ARE
JUMPING OCHON MY IPAD.
LOOK, BRANDON, ALSO YOU SEE
BRANDON TALKING ABOUT MICAH
PARSONS.
THERE GOES THE COMMENTS JUMPING
AGAIN.
BR BETTING IS TELLING YOU TO
PREACH, CONNER.
I'M GOING TO MAKE A DECISION.
I'M GOING TO MAKE A DOE SEECISI
WE'LL CALL THIS A BIAS DECISION.
IT IS WHAT IT IS.
I JUST WANT TO GIVE OUT MORE
HOODIES.
I GOT ISAAC BOATMAN WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE AND AARON SHAM 45
SAYS WATT IS THE MAN.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A HAD
HAD DE-- HOODIE.
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE A DECISION.
WE'RE GOING WITH TONY SIMPLY
BECAUSE HE MENTIONED NICK BOSA
AND THAT'S NOT THE REASON HE'S
GETTING THE JERSEY BUT, HE IS TE
WAS JUST BETTER.
BETTER VALUE AND CONNER MENTION
THAT AND NICK BOSA HAS 14 SACKS.
ONE GAME AWAY.
I STRONGLY FEEL HE'S ONE GAME
AWAY OF, YOU KNOW, MAKING HIS
CASE FOR DEFENSIVE PLAYER OF THE
YEAR.
SO WE'RE GOING TO ROCK WITH
TONY.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
I'LL SEND YOU A HOODIE AND LOVE
YOUR TAKE, BOTHROTHER.
LOVE YOUR TAKE.
>> IT TAKES ONE GAME.
AIDEN HUTCHINSON HAD TWO BIG
GAMES IN COLLEGE FOOTBALL AND
FLIPPED AS THE FAVORITE TO BE
THE NUMBER ONE OVERALL PICK.
WENT INTO THE HEISMAN ODDS.
THREE-SACK GAMES FLIPS THE ODDS.
KEEP AN EYE ON GARRETT AND WATT.
TOUGHER FOR THE INTERIOR
DEFENSIVE LINEMEN.
MOVING ON.
PROP SEGMENT.
WE'RE NOT GETTING OUT OF HERE
WITHOUT THE PROP SEGMENT.
IS IT A LOCK OR DROP?
GREG, WHAT PROPS ARE WE LOOKING
AT?
WE'LL GO ON THE OFFENSIVE SIDE
OF THE BALL THIS WEEK.
>> OKAY.
YOU GUYS LET US KNOW.
LET US KNOW IF IT'S A LOCK OR
NOT.
I NEED Y'ALL TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS.
FILL THEM THINGS UP.
Y'ALL KNOW WHAT TO DO.
LET'S GET INTO IT, CONNER.
LET'S START OFF WITH CORDELL
PATTERSON, CORDELL PATTERSON TO
RUSH FOR OVER OR UNDER 48 AND A
HALF YARDS.
HE LEADS ATLANTA IN RUSHING
YARDS.
SCRIMMAGE YARDS AND TOUCHES AND
THE FALCONS HAVE BEEN RUNNING
THE BALL LATELY, CONNER.
THEY'VE BEEN RUNNING THE BALL IN
THE LAST THREE GAMES THEY HAD
100-YARD RUSHER.
SO CONNER, IS THIS A LOCK?
IS THIS A LOCK?
ARE WE LOCKING THIS IN OR ARE WE
DROPPING IT?
IS CORDELL GOING TO GO OVER 48.5
AGAINST MY NINERS?
>> I'LL DROP IT.
WITH CORDELL AND I'VE BEEN A
CORDELL PROP BETTER THIS YEAR.
I LOOKED FOR ALL PURPOSE YARDS.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHICH ONE YOU'LL
GET BECAUSE THE FALCONS ARE
TRYING TO BE UNPREDICTABLE WITH
HIM WHETHER WORKHORSE RUNNER OR
TEN TARGET CORDARRELLE.
YOU GO ALL PURPOSE YARDS AND
GIVE YOURSELF INSURANCE NO
MATTER HOW HIGH THAT NUMBER
GOES, HE'S GOOD WITH HITTING IT.
48.5 IS NOT A LOT HERE, GREG.
THE PROBLEM IS, YOU KNOW THIS,
YOUR NINERS BESIDES THE SEATTLE
GAME THE LAST FIVE WEEKS, THEY
HAVEN'T ALLOWED ANYTHING ON THE
GROUND.
THE FALCONS ARE PREDICTABLE.
IT'S A SHAME.
THEY'VE LOST CALVIN RIDLEY.
KYLE PITTS.
TEAMS ARE KEYINQUEUEING IN.
THIS IS ONE I TRADITIONALLY STAY
AWAY FROM.
I'LL DROP IT.
>> CONNER, YOU'RE DROPPING IT.
AND I DON'T DISLIKE THAT BECAUSE
LIKE YOU MENTIONED, THE NINERS
DO PLAY THE RUN WELL.
THEY PLAY AND STIFLE RUNNING
BACKS WHEN THEY USUALLY FACE UP
AGAINST THE 49ERS.
BUT TODAY I SEE THINGS HAPPENING
A LITTLE DIFFERENT, CONNER.
I SEE THINGS HAPPENING A LITTLE
DIFFERENT.
WE'RE PLAYING AGAINST MATT RYAN
THAT LIKES TO THROW THE BALL
HISTORICALLY AGAINST A NINER HE
SLINGS.
WE'RE STRUGGLING AT CORNERBACK.
GUYS ARE DROPPING OUT LIKE
FLIES.
YOU GOT FIRST -- I MEAN, DRAFT
PICKS OUT THERE, ROOKIES OUT
THERE.
WE'RE STRUGGLING AT CORNERBACK
SO I SEE THE FALCONS COMING OUT,
THROWING THE BALL WITH
INTENTIONS TO THROWING THE BALL,
CONNER AND WITH THAT BEING SAID,
THAT WILL OPEN UP SOME LANES.
48.5 ISN'T -- I MEAN --
>> NOT CRAZY.
>> IT'S A HALF A CENTURY.
IT'S ALL MOST 100 YARDS BUT NOT
CRAZY.
THIS CAN HAPPEN IN TWO RUSHES,
TWO 25-YARD RUSHES YOU KNOW WHAT
I MEAN?
THIS CAN HAPPEN EASILY.
I'LL ROCK WITH THE OVER HERE.
I THINK I'M GOING TO ROCK WITH
OVER.
I DON'T SEE CORDELL PATTERSON
BEING A BAIL.
I DON'T SEE HIM BEING, YOU KNOW,
A BAIL IN THIS GAME OR TOTE IN
THE ROCK 25 PLUS TIMES BUT I CAN
SEE HIM GETTING 48.5 YARDS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE GOT ONE MORE PROP.
LET'S KNOCK IT OUT.
>> LET'S MOVE ON, CONNER.
LET'S MOVE ON BECAUSE I REALLY
LIKE THIS ONE.
I LIKE THIS ONE A LOT.
I KNOW YOU'LL LIKE THIS ONE.
WE GOT AARON ROGERS TO THROW
OVER OR UNDER 271.5 PASSING
YARDS.
CONNER, HE THREW FOR 341 LAST
WEEK AND FOR TUBS.
LET'S NOT FORGET TEN TOUCHDOWNS
AND NO INTERCEPTIONS IN THE PAST
THREE GAMES.
CONNER, HE NEEDS FOUR TOUCHDOWNS
TO PASS BRETT FAVRE FOR FIRST
PLACE ON THE PACKERS ALL TIME
LIST.
HE'S GOING TO BE HUNGRY.
>> YEAH.
>> HE'S GOING TO BE HUNGRY,
CONNER.
>> YEAH, LISTEN, YOU'RE ALL OVER
IT.
YOU'RE ON IT.
WHEN THERE IS A RECORD IN SIGHT
AND FOR A DUDE LIKE ROGERS, WE
SEEN THIS WITH BRADY.
THOSE TYPE OF DUDES, THEY SEE
RED.
THEY LOCK IN AND LET'S NOT
FORGET HERE, GREG, HE'S PLAYING
THE RAVINS WHO HAVE LOST
EVERYBODY AND AS WE WERE
PREPPING TO DO OUR SHOW TODAY,
JIMMY SMITH TESTED POSITIVE FOR
COVID.
SO IT'S LIKE THE ONION HEADLINE,
RIGHT?
THE MAN THAT LOST ALL HOPE
SEEMINGLY LOST HOPE HE DIDN'T
EVEN KNOW HE HAD.
THE RAVINS KEEP LOSING PLAYERS
THAT THEY DIDN'T EXPECT TO START
FOR THEM THIS YEAR.
SO THE POINT IS, AARON ROGERS IS
GOING TO COME OUT AND THROW THE
BALL AROUND THE YARD.
THE ONLY WAY HE DOESN'T HIT THIS
OVER IS IF THEY GET TOO EARLY OF
A LEAD AND HAVE TO RUN OUT THE
CLOCK.
SO OVER, OVER, OVER, LOCK IT IN.
>> CONNER IS ROCKING WITH THE
OVER, SO AM I.
I BET ON THIS RAVIN'S TEAM LAST
WEEK.
I BET ON -- THEY COVERED.
I BET THE MONEY LINE.
GOT IT FROM YOU, CONNER.
BET THE MONEY LINE.
>> NO BUENO.
>> THEY DID COVER.
ONE THING THAT'S BEEN CONSTANT
WITH THE RAVINS THIS YEAR IS
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN INJURED ON
THEIR TEAM.
THEY'VE BEEN DROPPING OUT LIKE
FLIES.
THAT DEFENSE IS INJURED.
HEY, AARON ROGERS, HE'S -- BAKER
MAYFIELD WAS THROWING THE BALL
IN THE FIRST HALF LAST WEEK.
HE'S NO AARON ROGERS SO GO GET
271.5.
I SEE THAT ACTUALLY BEING EASY
CONNER.
SO I'M ROCKING WITH YOU.
>> ALL RIGHT.
MOVING ON, PROPS LOOK GOOD THIS
WEEK.
I LIKE ROGERS.
YOU'RE STARTING TO SELL ME ON
C.P. A BIT.
BOLDEST BETS TIME.
YOU KNOW THE DEAL.
GREG AND I BRING OUR BOLDEST
BETS.
WE'LL ASK THE COMMENTS TO GET IT
DONE, RIGHT, GREG?
HOW WE FEELING ABOUT THE BOLDEST
BETS?
>> FEELING REAL, REAL, REAL GOOD
ABOUT THESE BETS, CONNER.
LET'S GET MONEY.
BEFORE WE GET TO IT, I NEED
EVERYBODY IN THE COMMENTS.
ARE YOU RIDING WITH ME OR
CONNER?
WE'LL WIN.
WE'LL GET PLUS MONEY.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT, CONNER.
>> CAME CLOSE.
UNDER DOG PARLAY, FALCONS WIN,
PARLAY 1-2.
NO HIT.
LET'S BOUNCE BACK AND GO BACK TO
THE TWO TOUCHDOWN SCORES.
GRONK AGAINST THE SAINTS, TWO
TOUCHDOWNS.
THAT'S ALL YOU GOT TO KNOW WITH
GRONK RIGHT NOW.
GRONK CATCHES THEM IN BUNCHES.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE THE GUTS
TO BUTT ON THEM TO CATCH ONE,
BET ON HIM TO CATCH TWO.
HE'S DONE IT THREE TIMES THIS
YEAR AND I THINK EVERY GAME HE'S
CAUGHT A TOUCHDOWN, HE'S CAUGHT
A SECOND ONE.
NOW BRADY DID NOT LOOK GOOD
AGAINST THE SAINTS THIS YEAR.
THIS IS A DEFENSE HE STRUGGLES
AGAINST BUT LET'S BE REAL.
THIS IS NOT THE SAME SAINTS
TEAM.
BRADY GETS ANGRY OFF THE
PERFORMANCES AND HOLDS THE
GRUDGE.
LOOKS TO RUN IT UP.
GRONK ON THE FIELD.
BET GRONK TWO TOUCHDOWNS PLUS
750.
THOSE ARE JUICY ODDS.
GREG, WHERE ARE YOU GOING THIS
WEEK?
>> CONNER, I LOVE THAT.
CONNER, ROB GRONKOWSKI IS
ACTUALLY ON MY FANTASY TEAM.
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER ON THE
SHOW FOR THE PEOPLE THAT DID NOT
MAKE THEIR FANTASY PLAYOFFS,
FEEL SORRY FOR THEM AND ME
BECAUSE I DIDN'T MAKE THE
PLAYOFFS BUT THAT IS OKAY,
CONNER.
HAD A BUSY, BUSY SCHEDULE THIS
SEASON.
WE'RE NOT MAKING NO EXECUTIONS.
LOVE THAT PLAY, CONNER.
LOVE THAT PLAY.
BUT I THREW A CURVEBALL.
I THREW A KAUFGCURVEBALL AT YOU
CONNER, THE PRODUCERS AND
SEGMENT BOLDEST BETS AND ALSO
THREW A CURVEBALL AT EVERYBODY
IN THE COMMENTS BECAUSE COMING
RIGHT NOW IS A LOCK.
I THINK THIS ONE IS GOING TO
HIT.
I THINK THIS ONE WILL BE EASY.
WE HAVE RUSSELL WILSON, MATTHEW
STAFFORD TO HAVE OVER 1.5
PASSING TOUCHDOWNS IN THE GAME
TODAY.
WE KNOW WHAT MATT STAFFORD AND
SEAN McVEIGH IS COOKING UP.
WE KNOW.
THEY'VE BEEN HOT.
THEY'VE BEEN COOKING IT UP IN
L.A. BUT WE ALSO KNOW WHAT
RUSSELL WILSON DOES AND THIS IS
A DEFENSIVE -- DIVISION MATCHUP,
CONNER.
THIS IS A DIVISION MATCHUP.
WE KNOW WHAT RUSSELL WILSON HAS
BEEN DOING IN HIS DIVISION FOR
THE LAST I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
YEARS AND HE'S FACING THIS RAM'S
TEAM, A TEAM THAT HE FACES
CONSTANTLY EVERY YEAR.
AND HE DOES HIS FAIR SHARE.
HE DOES HIS FAIR SHARE OF
PUTTING UP NUMBERS AGAINST THIS
RAM'S TEAM AND I CAN SEE IT
HAPPENING TODAY.
ALL THEY HAVE TO DO IS GET TWO
TOUCHDOWNS EACH.
I CAN SEE THIS HAPPENING.
SO I'M GOING TO ROCK WITH THIS.
I'LL ROCK WITH THIS MATT
STAFFORD, RUSSELL WILSON, GO GET
TWO TOUCHDOWNS, MAN.
>> I LIKE IT, GREG.
I THINK STAFFORD KNOCKS IN OUT
FOR YOU IN THE FIRST HALF.
YOU NEED FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
THROW AND THIS IS A DIVISION
GAME, WHICH MEANS IT WILL BE
CLOSE, WHICH MEANS HE'S GOING TO
HAVE TO AT SOME POINT THROW THE
BALL DOWN THE FIELD.
SEATTLE'S COACHES NEED TO LET
HIM DO THAT.
SO I LIKE THIS PICK.
TWO TOUCHDOWNS EACH IS NOTHING
CRAZY AT ALL.
SO I LOVE THAT YOU FOUND THIS.
PLUS 170.
THIS IS AWESOME.
>> FUNNY, MAN.
>> THIS IS A GOOD FIND FROM GREG
HERE.
SO WE NEED TWO THINGS RIGHT NOW,
GREG.
WE NEED THE COMMENTS TO LET US
KNOW WHO THEY ARE RIDING WITH
AND I THINK WE HAVE A GIVE AWAY
IN YOUR POCKET FOR THIS WEEK'S
SHOW.
LET'S DO THAT BEFORE WE GET OUT
OF HERE.
>> HERE WE GO.
HERE WE GO.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS, MAN.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I GOT A BIG MIKE 13 SAYS
CURVEBALL, GREG.
CURVEBALL.
SHOUT
SHOUTOUT TO YOU BIG MIKE 13.
THAT'S WORTHY OF A JERSEY.
SORRY.
I THINK THIS IS WORTHY OF A
JERSEY BECAUSE MY GUY THREW THE
CURVEBALL AT US.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
WE'RE GETTING SPAMMED BY SNAIL.
THAT IS NOT -- THAT'S NOT HOW
YOU GET A HOODIE J.J. SNAIL.
AT SPECS 24 SAYS ALMOST ALMOST
OR COAST.
I MEAN, I GUESS YOU ARE ALMOST
CLOSE TO GETTING THE JERSEY.
I'LL GIVE YOU A HOODIE FOR THAT.
CONNER, I'M JUST GIVING OUT
TAKE.
I'M GIVING OUT HOODIE FOR TAKE.
88 JACKS GOING TO BLOW OUT THE
TEXANS.
URBAN IS FREE.
GIVE YOU A HOODIE FOR THAT.
CONNER, I'M DONE.
I'M DONE GIVING OUT THESE
HOODIES.
THE PEOPLE ROCKING WITH ME AND
ROCKING WITH YOU.
IS THIS VIBES ALL AROUND.
GOOD VIBES ALL AROUND.
>> WEEK 15, EVERYBODY IS FEELING
GOOD.
WE'RE AT THE FINISH LINE HERE.
"THE SQUAD RIDE" IS STILL
ROLLING.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT THAT.
THAT'S A WRAP, EVERYONE.
HUGE CONGRATULATIONS TO THE
WINNERS.
SHOUTOUT TO "THE SQUAD RIDE"
LEADER.
TYLER AND PROANGLER WHO ALWAYS
BRINGS THE HEAT, AS WELL.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMENTERS.
IF YOU WANT A HOODIE, DON'T
WORRY, B.R. BETTING WILL D.M.
YOU WITHIN THE NEXT 24 HOURS.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, ENJOY WEEK
15, EVERYBODY.
I'M CONNER ROGERS ALONGSIDE
GREG.
WE'LL CATCH YOU SAME TIME, SAME
PLACE NEXT WEEK.